ohnehin sei die erste grüne
elite pommes lp hallo kolb kraft und
data sämtlicher ist geld geborgt gerne
unsterblich sein sakko mit ja nein hätte
ich finde einfach euch hat denn jeder
gerne unsterblich ist wenn jeder
unsterblich ist jetzt werden wir das
problem dass ihr viele menschen werden
das ist viel zu viel chaos gibt weil
alle möglichen leute irgendwie stolz
machen würden von hochhäusern springen
würden sich flugzeuge schnappen würden
und irgendwie rumfliegen wird weil es
kann ja nicht sterben
das war einfach viel zu bescheuert gibt
für mich keinen sinn in der materie von
level zu level zu level zu level ich
also ich war ein internationaler habe
mir glas gegen volle getauscht
das war bestimmt meiner ja jetzt kommt
eure meinung wird das glas die pause gar
kein glas die was war das die
schlüssigste und sterblichkeit wenn
jeder unsterblich wäre
wie findest du das denn
na gut dann wär halt unsere gesellschaft
komplett anders organisiert kann man
denn dann noch kinder zeugt verboten
was wir dann überhaupt noch organisiert
denen du dich schnell mal vor was
passieren würde alles stellt ihrer
letztlich dasselbe daily x früher
stell dir mal vor es wird in 2000 jahren
die erde ist kurz vom kollabieren weg
war 30 oder wird nicole in ihr wird eine
gruppe ausgewählt die bekommen tränke
die man der frau erfunden hat dass man
unsterblich wird und sie lassen sich auf
einen neuen erdähnlichen planeten wieder
den mann gefunden hat wie man dahin
kommt wurde das dann auch erfunden und
dort sind sie unsterblich und müssen
halt deswegen neue gesellschaft
organisieren und eine neue
gesellschaftsform und wie soll das
organisiert werden das ist ja du kann
man die frage um nehmen wenn du damit
jetzt auch in 2012 hier andeuten willst
dann muss ich leider sagen aber wenn
dagegen eine gruppe einmal ausgewählt
wird
ich bin gut einem jahr wären die dann
einen schrank haben um unsterblich zu
werden und wenn die dann da irgendwie
auf einem planeten geben wo man leben
kann und blau und bla dann kann man
theoretisch diese ganze dieses
kollabieren aushalten wenn sie soweit
sind
das wird einfach nicht passieren es gibt
keinen kranken dem du sterblich ist es
geht der islam da sagte ich ja dass das
einfach wenn man das mal als gegeben
ansieht ansehen würde also dass das so
ist und dann wie die dann die
organhandel hat das jetzt gar nicht so
mit und schnelligkeit zu tun was bleibt
wenn wenn du ihren jetzt wie alle
unsterblich werden
die fed hatte doch es war ein
gedankenexperiment das nicht so doch da
darf ich trotzdem dann wenn du dann
stelle ich für dich locker weil einfache
frage wie komme ich aus dem aus einem
labyrinth heraus aus deinem nach
vielleicht nur raus jetzt gefunden du
musst nicht sagen
doch nein antwortet doch mal vernünftig
was hältst du davon wenn du jetzt auf
einmal unsterblich wärst was würdest du
dann sagen ich würde erstmal von einem
hochhaus springen allein weiteren geiles
gefühl es zu fliehen
keine ahnung ich glaube da muss man dann
muss man ganz viele fragen der
menschheit neu machen zum beispiel gibt
es einen gott
und was macht gott wenn du toll selbst
mal anders formuliert die frage jetzt
nicht wenn man jetzt zum sterblich wer
blabla sondern würdest du gerne
unsterblich sein bloß nicht hervor der
stress wir eigentlich auch nicht
gänzlich
aber ich würde gerne gebe ich so 25
jahre alt sein oder so nicht irgendwann
mit 60 oder 70 es wahrscheinlich schon
irgendwo geiler wenn du so weil ich
nicht so im bereich welche nicht 16 bis
das so gilt die deine hochzeit
und wenn du das du ewig konnten konnten
wir konservieren würdest könnte rasieren
konvertieren
was willst du eigentlich auch das frage
ich mich auch mal bei seinen ganzen
ansetzen
ich versuche die teilweise relativ
freien fragen so umzudeuten ist dass sie
so einen sinn haben dass du versuchst
niveau reinzubringen
ja das war ich sagen aber er gleitet
dabei einfach immer so am thema vorbei
es war die frage was würdest du jetzt
gern und treppen kann er kommt an
ja ich werde jetzt gerne 25 jahre die
ganze zeit so für immer jung soo park
sein und so du sollst sagen ob du gerne
jetzt unsterblich werden und dazu dann
die begründungen nicht mit ihn geheilt
anderen sterblich dass ich dabei immer
noch das heißt dass du nicht egal wie
alt du bist unsterblich hast du nichts
tut
zudem erweiterte ewig 18 1 durch huggel
wie es halt ganz normal alt und dann
irgendwie in dem alter von so seien 80
wald so die meisten alten leute die halt
noch gesund sind halt dann jemand auch
kopieren
in dem alter legst du einfach weiter und
wird halt immer eltern verschrumpelt
dann irgendwie so aber du bist ja
richtig kacke deswegen ja das ist
natürlich blöd aber darum habe ich doch
dieses diese neuen aspekt es kommt
darauf an ich will nicht ewig in dem
zustand in dem 80 lena will man doch
nicht ewig eben kein wort mehr
aber wenn du ewig um also sage ich mal
zwischen 16.35 in dem alter irgendwas
bist da kommen doch ewig leben des doch
angenehm denn das noch frage da sind
alle fragen ja sozusagen der innen mit
inbegriffen war erreichen kann
die frage nach dem grund des nach dem
sinn sehen auch was nach dem tod
passiert so zu sagen weil willmann weil
wenn wir jetzt an dem wir das nach dem
tod einfach ein kompletter de zellmasse
alles was er drin sein irgendwie halt
nicht mehr funktioniert kollabiert und
man deswegen dann logischerweise gar
nicht mehr denken kann nach nichts mehr
denkt und so weiter und so fort
dann gibt's ja nichts nachdem todes also
die frage will man einfach weg sein oder
will man noch irgendwas erleben im leben
und darum unsterblich sein
ich glaube der tod macht leben erst
lebenswert und man hier so man richtig
episch ist philosophisches zitat
reinzubringen
jetzt dürft ihr damit weiterhin will ein
zitat und man lebt um zu sterben
ich baue ich jetzt übrigens einfach nach
oben weil ich kein ausländer ja ich lebe
weil ich würd gern immer 25 sein und
deswegen steckt
auf jeden fall glaube ich mehr als
lukratives geschäft für beide oder mehr
als ich auch als ich hab n twitter
account und so weiter aber ich also so
ich zwitschert auch manchmal folge ja
echt
wenig leuten dann habe ich mal dena
gefolgt und dann kam da einfach nichts
angedacht dann halten die abonnierte die
abo bei youtube soll verstehe den sinn
über 100 wenn jemand keine sachen bringt
zum beispiel videos auf youtube
warum sollte man denn dann jemand
abonniert doch um zu warten um zu sehen
wenn etwas kommt warum der abonniert
manchmal lz wird das auch bei mir so ich
folge leuten mit denen ich dann wirklich
auch aktiv da nehmen die was antworten
kann schreiben kann wenn ich nichts mehr
twittern nicht
jetzt mal ganz kurz was diese wieder mal
13 15
das sind 19 wir haben anderthalb minuten
wieder ein neues thema
und das wird dann auch schon das
förderliche hätten es gerade hier den
dna von hinten schauen wer da ein
bisschen schnell wie ich und keaton sei
dies zu grüne jackett skate bereits
dicht bist mit deinem haus weil das
jetzt noch genau zwei folgen 30 26
minuten
das wird knapp du hast acht bekommen
oder 10c nicht willst du da wie viele
baumann für den v-mann für den kings
table 988 nein ich mir das ist
vielleicht für die tests für den table
bern 4 3 oder 4 oder 3 unten oder
bekommt man sogar 5 ich glaub man bauen
und drei unten wartet kurz nach ändert
steigern
da brauchen wir noch ein anderer seite
in der zweiten reihe also also fünf mal
was zu essen und dann dinge wie essen
hier essen hier essen hier kartoffeln
gebratene ja hast du mich niemand
braucht und länder auge nein das meine
ich brenne für den in chongqing table
diese will sondern chapman table bauen
ich habe doch als 20 20 level okay kohle
okay endverbrauch wir hatten schon mal
so viele level und du willst kann john
terry ich will so schnell wie möglich
haben um endlich meine level härter aber
damit ich dir jeder verliert wenn ich
sterbe darauf folgenden anderson sterben
dafür braucht man viel oxidieren zwei
diamanten und einem buch online ich habe
ja man wie viele du brauchst zwei stück
oder zwei diamanten und vier oxidieren
also und torszenen das heißt braucht
noch 22 er braucht noch zwei er wollte
hast doch zehn du brauchst 8 für deinen
ob sie den chester so dass jetzt auch
schon einberechnet okay gut dann will
ich erstmal appell so schnell wo es vier
du bist so gut es geht
ich suche nur die schere wir wollen
schlafen und du ich suche eine schwere
was tust du was hast du dir genommen
dass seine speziellen genommen nein
keine schere ihr dann im zweiten
was braucht man noch mal um ende auge
zumachen weil ich place powder in der
auge also wir brauchen mehr obsidian die
posten der inder perle von mendler und
lassen keinen doppelbett place rott oder
von leather er war noch gar nicht besser
oder genauso eine tolle position bei und
so ganz chronisch legen uns jetzt
schlafen ja ich lege jetzt gleich in dem
bett news kate noch im bett du kannst
mir kinderfilm hätte bestimmt schaut die
baustelle kleider aus richtung crafter
den park vor sorgen die baustelle den
und ich war nur am plappern und zwar
ganz einfach da sein haus gewollt war
trotzdem daran die fertig weil einfach
mit seinen videos geguckt hat weil es
einfach immer gleich bei allen videos
karthaus cook jetzt mal gehört jetzt
sieht auch echt nicht schlecht aus aber
trotzdem luca einmal schnell kann ich
schon mal das portal baum hat mir nicht
neues thema so vor eineinhalb minuten
erwartet das soll ich jetzt eben sagen
und portal kannst mir noch sagen dann
baue ich dann noch in schnell
hallo portal erwartet 22 sind vier sind
zehn brauchst dafür ich hätte ein thema
ist e zigarette für zwölfjährige ok oder
sollten sie nur für ältere zulässig
seien von xxx loki lp xxx wo kommt denn
die diskussion her dass e zigaretten für
minderjährige nicht auch alternativen an
systeme
das ist da könntest du genauso china für
minderjährige erlauben oder so das
prinzip ist ja dass uns einfach mal über
rauchen reden sage ich mal
oder die zitate mit dem apetito
covershow wieso sucht den halter für
besseren thema als konnte jetzt halt die
schnauze du warst die ganze zeit damit
beschäftigt kommentare rauszusuchen die
negativ waren über unser verhalten hier
ich habe denen gesagt das ganze geld
sogar bezeugen dann kommt skater mit
ihnen solchen vielen themen die auch von
uns verantwortet haben will über die
beziehung besser nicht reden weil man
darüber reden wenn ich gut oder wo wir
denn das webportal hinmachen ich baue
das jetzt vorbei ich mich das färbe ich
mich ja warte ich finde es meine hören
aber die sache eher schön
die sache ist wirklich gewesen dass wir
keine kommentare gefunden haben weil
einfach so wenig kommentar fragen
gestellt werden
das ist einfach so das verstehe ich auch
gar nicht wenn der gute kommentar frage
habt seht meine ich seht dann gibt's im
bitten daumen nach oben damit wird es
leicht oder von mir aus ist mir auch
egal
das könnte auch das gleiche nochmal
schreiben in etwas abgewandelten form
nur damit wir es halt irgendwie dann
sehen
überall wird doch mal sagen die können
auch als unsere facebook seiten themen
schreiben oder weil da bin ich
eigentlich öfter drin als jede minute
kommen
ja aber ich finde das eigentlich schon
ganz nähern ein wahnsinnig macht sich
hört auch hört sofort auch über allen
themen verschreibt sie bitte nur
zumindest für mich mir könnt ihr auch
noch die aktuellen folge menschen eine
der aktuellsten folgen einfach rein weil
ein kunde vor der aufnahme einfach in
die tasche folgen reingucken in die
alten und schauen wo der themen
verstehen sind
weil dann vielleicht hat auch immer von
facebook geschrieben
vielleicht hat die mamas bett später
geschrieben vielleicht hat jemand was
bei google+ geschrieben aber gut das ist
ja niemand richtig das brauchst du gar
nicht erst annehmen